انجلينا جولي تقول كلمتها حول ضحايا غزه
هجوم على بيومي فؤاد وسط استمرار الجدل
بشان المشاركات الفنيه المصريه في موسم
الرياض تصريح صادم لجمهور ندين نجيم وظهور
نادر لسيلين ديون اليكم الابرز في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع سجلت الممثله الامريكيه انجلينا
جولي موقفا واضحا تجاه الضحايا المدنيين
في غزه وذلك من خلال صوره نشرتها لاحدى
المناطق السكنيه المدمره علقت عليها
بالقول هذا هو القصف المتعمد لسكان
المحاصرين ليس لديهم مكان للهرب كانت غزه
سجنا مفتوحا منذ ما يقارب من عقدين من
الزمان وتتحول بسرعه الى مقبره جماعيه 40%
من القتلى هم اطفال ابرياء على حد وصفها
وفي نفس السياق يتواصل دعم العديد من
الفنانين المصريين لجهود الاغاثه ويتطوع
للمشاركه في حمله الهلال الاحمر المصري
لتجهيز المساعدات وارسالها لغزه ومنها ما
يصل من دول عربيه واجنبيه وكان الهلال
الاحمر المصري قد توجه بالشكر للفنان عمرو
دياب على تبرعه لدعم جهود الاغاثه في
غزه ولا يزال الجدل مستمرا على منصات
التواصل في مصر حول مشاركه فنانين مصريين
في موسم الرياض واعاده الى الواجهه مقطع
فيديو تم تداوله للفنان المصري بيومي فؤاد
بشكل واسع على منصات التواصل توجه فيه
للجمهور السعودي في ختام اح عروض مسرحيه
زواج اصطناعي بدا فيه منفعلا وهو يؤكد على
ما تعرض له فريق المسرحيه من ظلم على حد
قوله جيت المملكه العربيه السعوديه وليه
الشرف احنا ما بنجيش عشان نضحك حضراتكم
احنا بنقدم بنقدم فننا وانتقد فؤاد زميله
الفنان محمد سلام الذي انسحب من المسرحيه
تضامنا مع الضحايا المدنيين في غزه دون ان
ياتي على ذكر اسمه من حقك انك تعتذر عن
المسرحيه لكن مش من حقك انك تغلط في فنك
وتباينت ردود الافعال على على كلام بيومي
فؤاد في الفيديو المتداول وطغى عليها موجه
من الانتقادات الحاده وكان للاعلامي
المصري عمر اديب رد حاد في برنامجه
الحكايه على المنتقدين للفنانين المصريين
المشاركين في موسم الرياض اللي انتم
بتعملوه مع بيومي فواد ده واي حد يهاجم اي
فنان انا هدافع عنه انا المحامي بتاعهم
موسم الرياض مستمر ومش
هيقف ومع استمرار فعالياته شهد موسم
الرياض حفلا جماهيريا للمطرب السعودي عبد
المجيد عبد الله الاسبوع
الماضي ما شفتك في ديك الليله
صدفه ومن الرياض وخلال لقاء اعلامي فجرت
الفنانه اللبنانيه ندين نجيم مفاجاه من
العيار الثقيل لجمهورها حينما اعلنت في
اجابه على مضيفتها انها تعتقد ان قرار
اعتزالها التمثيل سيكون
قريبا
اخيرا احتفى محب الفنانه الكنديه سلين
ديون بظهور نادر لها بعد الاعلان عن
اصابتها بمتلازمه الشخص المتيبس والغاء
جميع انشطتها الفنيه ديون حضرت مباراه في
هوكي الجليد بلاس فيغاس وظهرت في الصور
التي نشرتها عبر حسابها الرسمي على
انستغرام الى جانب ابنائها ريني تشارلز
والتوام نيلسون
وايدي